sie wollte mit ihren Komplizen Karl
Lauterbach entführen absolut irre das
Land ins Chaos stürzen sie hier
Elisabeth r75 Jahre alt aus Sachsen die
Frau mit dem Kartoffelsack bestens
vernetzt mit der rechtsextremen
reisberger ja nach ihrer Festnahme fragt
sich nun ganz Deutschland wer ist
eigentlich diese terroroma die diese
perfiden Pläne geschmiedet hat
per Polizeihubschrauber auf direkten
Wege zum Ermittlungsrichter terroroma im
Anflug Elisabeth R ehemaliger Lehrerin
aus Flöha im Landkreis Mittelsachsen 75
Jahre alt sie soll Terror Chefin sein
ihr Plan die Entführung von Karl
Lauterbach Rückblick 13 April 2022 vier
mutmaßliche Täter allesamt deutsche
werden festgenommen der Verdacht sie
sind Anhänger einer terroristischen
Vereinigung mit dem Namen vereinte
Patrioten ihr Ziel Bürgerkrieg ähnliche
Zustände den Sturz der Bundesregierung
und der Demokratie außerdem wollen sie
offenbar die Stromversorgung in
Deutschland zerstören und so einen
bundesweiten Blackout verursachen und
eben ihm zu entführen
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach die
Gruppierung vereinte Patrioten entsteht
aus einer telegram-gruppe ihre Anhänger
Querdenker Impfgegner und Reichsbürger
hier einer der Köpfe der Gruppe gewohnt
haben Sven B aus Falkensee im Keller
seines Einfamilienhauses finden die
Beamten eine SS-Uniform und diese
Kalaschnikow er unauffällig verläuft die
Razzia bei der terroroma in Flöha ein
Nachbar ist aber dennoch überrascht von
dem kriminellen Gedankengut seiner
Nachbarin der hatte ja zurückgezogen
gelebt also mir hatten wie gesagt da
keinen Kontakt und auch eigentlich hat
sie auch nie gegrüßt und deswegen sehr
zurückgezogen eigentlich ja wenn man
dann gerade im Sommer draußen sitzt noch
ein bisschen länger und gegrillt hat und
dann fröhlicher Runde und dann fing dann
so gegen 22 Uhr hörte man dann irgendwo
ein Rasenmäher so ein Elektrorasenmäher
dann losgehen und das war dann eben der
Nachbarin da hat man dann die Stirnlampe
gesehen der hat schon die Standlampe
immer dazu noch hat die dann eben auch
Gartenarbeit um die Zeit vorher
verrichtet die terroroma soll sich um
Waffen und Sprengstoff gekümmert haben
und
rekrutierungsgespräche mit potenziellen
vereinigungsmitgliedern geführt haben
mit dem Helikopter wurde die 75 Geld zum
Bundesgerichtshof nach Karlsruhe
geflogen und wird dort dem
Ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt der
entscheidet nun über den Vollzug der
Untersuchungshaft
ja vor der terroroma ist Karl Lauterbach
zunächst sicher wir haben den
Betroffenen also ihn gestern auch dazu
befragt
ich kenne diese Frauen nicht und von dem
was ich also gehört und gesehen habe
lege ich auch keinen Wert darauf dass
wir uns begegnen es ist einfach so die
Ermittlungen laufen mehr kann man dazu
nicht sagen und wie gesagt danke an die
Kollegen vom BKA die den guten Schutz
hier für uns organisieren wie groß ist
die Erleichterung bei ich bin froh dass
es also jetzt erstmal zu dieser
Verhaftung gekommen ist aber ich arbeite
einfach weiter wir haben sehr viel
Arbeit zu tun derzeit das ist der
Schwerpunkt das sind die Dinge die mich
im Moment mehr beschäftigen als die
eigene Sicherheit da fühle ich mich gut
geschützt
ja fühlt sich also gut geschützt sagt
Karl Lauterbach darüber müssen wir
sprechen mit Michael Kur er ist
Personenschützer uns jetzt zugeschaltet
schönen guten Morgen Herr Kur schönen
guten Morgen also ohne zu viel zu
verraten jetzt wie genau schützt man
denn einen Karl Lauterbach einen
gefährdeten Minister
also nicht nur ja lauter aber auch alle
Minister
Leben Moment sehr gefährlich ja sie sind
gefährdet ich denke sie sind die
gefährtesten Menschen in Deutschland und
ein Glückwunsch an alle
Personenschützer von der Polizei dass
sie es bis heute geschafft haben dass
unsere Politiker
gesund geblieben sind ja also top die
machen einen Top-Job und das ganze
funktioniert natürlich nur mit einem
super Team wo die Kommunikation
stimmt und auch Manpower genügt da ist
um
eben für Schutz zu sorgen das ist ja
mehr als nur ein 24 Stunden Job was sind
denn die Situation wo sie sagen da wird
es mir als Personenschützer Angst das
sind die Situationen wo ich Ministern
eher davon abrate
ja das ist natürlich
da wo viele Menschen sind
da wird es gefährlich ja weil das ist
alles schwer einzuschätzen ob da
Menschen sind die psychische gestört
sind die Amokläufer sind oder die
einfach wirklich die Nerven verlieren
weil eben teilweise die Politik ja nicht
verstanden wird und viele Menschen
verlieren ja ihre Existenz und da kann
es vorkommen erst recht wenn man sich
mit der Schutzperson in der Masse begibt
dass da jemand weiß der komplett seine
Nerven verliert weil er eben teilt mit
seiner Nerven am Ende ist haben Sie
persönlich mal so eine Situation erlebt
was war für Sie in Ihrem Job die
brenzliste Situation die sie so erlebt
haben
wir arbeiten einen großen Team und wenn
es denn dazu kommt dass da ein Angriff
kommt auf unsere schutzpersonen ist das
dann haben wir da schon etwas gemacht
also bis heute hatte ich aufgrund
guter Vorarbeit im es geschafft dass
kein Angreifer kein eventueller
Attentäter an meine Schutzperson
rankommen konnte also ich kann sagen
bisher hat bei uns alles perfekt
geklappt weil wir ein starkes Team haben
und das hat auch das haben auch unsere
Politiker die haben sehr sehr gut
ausgebildete Polizisten die für die
Sicherheit unserer Politiker sorgen
Michael Kuhr ganz herzlichen Dank für
diese Eindrücke und für ja die
Erzählungen
gern
[Musik]